romans 8 18 through 25 for i consider
that the sufferings of this present time
are not worth comparing with the glory
that is to be revealed to us for the
creation waits with eager longing for
the revealing of the sons of god for the
creation was subjected to futility not
willingly but because of him who
subjected it in hope that the creation
itself will be set free from its bondage
to corruption and obtain the freedom of
the glory of the children of god for we
know that the whole creation has been
groaning together in the pains of
childbirth until now and not only the
creation but we ourselves who have the
firstfruits of the Spirit groan inwardly
as we wait eagerly for adoption as sons
the redemption of our bodies for in this
hope we were saved now hope that is seen
is not hope for who hopes for what he
sees but if we hope for what we do not
see we wait for it with patience Easter
has come the Lord is risen and yet the
world continues to barrel on the way it
always has we Christians believe that
the resurrection of Jesus Christ brings
about a whole new creation the old has
passed away the new has triumphantly
come the reign of our God has begun on
earth through his own chosen king and
that rain brings about an era of peace
an era of healing an era of good tidings
were all sin all suffering is done away
and the world is filled with the
knowledge and the worship of the one
true God and yet and yet corruption
continues to be the order of the day
corrupt governments around the world
remain in power economic inequality
remains entrenched injustice so often
prevails and human souls the world
/ continue to feel the weight of their
own brokenness their own weakness their
own wounds their own resentments their
own isolation their fear their shame
their doubts and now as we perhaps know
better than we ever have before our race
continues to be helpless against the
ravages of a natural world which groans
under the weight of a curse we marvel as
a microscopic entity of proteins and and
RNA brings the whole world with all of
its technological marvels to its knees
Christ is risen so we proclaim and yet
the world is still fallen despite
appearances the Scriptures would have us
be assured that the resurrection of our
Lord Jesus Christ does it truly change
everything it has given us a genuine
hope in a world to come and that is no
small thing consider how the Apostle
Paul in the eighth chapter of his letter
to the Romans looks out upon a world and
sees so much glory in the midst of
suffering he looks out and he sees a
creation subjected to humility verse 20
he sees it in bondage to corruption in
verse 21 he sees God's people groaning
inwardly verse 23 and yet he has the
audacity to say that I consider the
sufferings of this present time are not
worth comparing with the glory that will
be revealed to us now this is a
remarkable thing coming from the likes
of the Apostle Paul consider this some
hands own sufferings again and again in
his letters he lists them in a fantastic
way he has been beaten
he has been ostracized he has been
chased around he has been in danger for
his own life he has been shipwrecked he
has been marooned he has often been
hungry he has often been without
bleep he's in danger from false brethren
he's in danger from false teachers he's
in danger from his own churches who
sometimes rise up against him and yet in
the midst of all of these things he says
also on top of them I have my anxiety
for the churches consider what a man
this was that in the midst of all of
these bodily pains and deprivation
he would have as his most severe
suffering his fear for the people whom
he loves whom he serves and yet and yet
I consider the sufferings of this
present time are not worth comparing
with the glory that will be revealed to
us this is Paul's faith this is the hope
that he now has because our Lord is
risen indeed and even more than this he
sees by the virtue of Good Friday turn
to Easter Sunday that the sufferings of
the Christian are actually used by God
to unite us even more perfectly to our
Lord and Savior the suffering one that
we may more perfectly share in the glory
of his resurrection coming from the
Apostle Paul this is no pious platitude
this is no empty conceit he is not being
naive he is not being insensitive this
is one who knows what it's like to
suffer he has seen the worst that our
world can offer and yet he rejoices and
now we as God's people we groan inwardly
yes but we groan with eager anticipation
the image here is of a young child
waiting at the Christmas tree days
before Christmas day eager to open his
presents he feels the angst of that
longing so near and yet so far they are
of course the analogy only works because
he expects that he will one day get to
open the presents and likewise we
Christians though we grow inwardly we
know that our hope is sure and that it
is not in vain and this steals us to
endure patiently this strengthens us to
endure to run the race that is set
before us not because the sufferings
that we continue to face don't vex us
not because they don't
hurt not because they don't frustrate us
not even because sometimes we do waver
in doubt but because we have seen in
Jesus Christ just how powerful God is to
turn our groanings into glory and so now
in this time of pandemic it is upon us
to be constant in our prayers now is the
time for us to be fervent in our hope
now is the time for us to be intentional
in our joy
let us sing praises to God in this
season I'm mindful of a friend of mine
out in Massachusetts right now a fellow
clergyman who as he looks out upon the
world all he can say is I must continue
constant in my daily prayers and tell
this plague passes and that is our
outlook that is the power of the
churches daily faithfulness that is the
power of God's people remaining constant
now is the time for us to commend
ourselves to God now is the time for us
to trust in him now is the time for us
to make good on our faith and to serve
our fellow brothers and sisters in the
Lord because none of the pain in this
world
none of the evil in this world not even
global pandemics can change this one
fact that Jesus Christ is raised that
Jesus Christ is glorified and as we have
hope in his kingdom come on earth on
this earth as it is in heaven
we have great assurance god be praised